WUP, EVERYBODY?
YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE GROUP
CHAT LIVE IN THE "BLEACHER
REPORT" APP.
I'M GREG IVORY.
SHE'S BACK, YES, LIV MOODS.
WE ARE NOW ON EVERY THURSDAY
INSTEAD OF TUESDAY.
SO MARK THOSE CALENDARS.
THE BIG NEWS, BIG NEWS THIS WEEK
FOR LOUISIANA, SPORTS BETTING
GOES LIVE TOMORROW MORNING, LIV.
FANDUEL IS OFFERING SOMETHING
VERY, VERY SPECIAL TO THOSE OF
YOU IN LOUISIANA.
LIV, TALK TO THE PEOPLE AND TELL
THEM WHAT'S UP.
>> YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
FANDUEL IS OFFERING A $100 BONUS
TO BETTORS IN LOUISIANA IF YOU
REGISTER EARLY BEFORE FANDUEL
GOES LIVE THERE TOMORROW.
SO, YOU GUYS KNOW WHAT TO DO.
RUSH OVER TO THE FANDUEL SPORTS
BOOK, GET THAT $100 SO WE CAN
CASH OUT ALL WEEKEND LONG.
>> LIV, I GOT TO KNOW, YOU TALK
ABOUT CASHING OUT ALL WEEKEND
LONG.
IF YOU WERE TO GET THIS HUNDRED,
IF FANDUEL WOULD BLESS YOU WITH
A HUNDRED, WHAT WOULD YOUR
HUNDRED DOLLAR LOCK BE FOR THIS
WEEKEND?
>> TOMORROW.
I'M LOOKING AT THE GRIZZLIES AT
HOME TAKING ON THE JAZZ.
A WESTERN CONFERENCE MATCH-UP.
THE GRIZZLIES I FEEL LIKE ARE
STILL TRYING TO PROVE WHERE THEY
STAND IN THE WESTERN CONFERENCE.
I THINK THEY'RE STILL BEING
UNDERESTIMATED.
JOHN MORANE DOING HIS THING.
>> WE HAVE THE NETS TAKING ON
THE WARRIORS, YOU KNOW WHAT SIDE
I'M ROCKING WITH.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE WARRIORS.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD DO WITH THE
HUNDRED.
NO MATTER WHERE YOU LIVE, RIGHT
HERE RIGHT NOW WE ARE GIVING
AWAY LOCKS.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND
WE'RE GIVING AWAY JERSEYS.
GET IN THOSE COMMENTS, START
USING YOUR TWITTER FINGERS, YOUR
INSTAGRAM FINGERS, YOUR
"BLEACHER REPORT" FINGERS,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, GIVE ME
GIFS, EMOJIS, MOST IMPORTANTLY,
I THINK THEY KNOW THE PHRASE
RIGHT NOW.
>> WINNERS ONLY PLEASE.
>> TELL THEM, MAN.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED.
WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
IN FACT, THE PRODUCER WHISPERED
IN MY EAR, GIVE AWAY A JERSEY.
I'M ABOUT TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY
RIGHT NOW TO SOMEBODY IN THE
COMMENTS.
I SEE BENNY SAYS CAT
DOUBLE-DOUBLE.
I LIKE CAT TO HAVE A DECENT
GAME.
TO HAVE A DECENT GAME.
VEGAS IS CALLING ME.
I CAN'T.
I HAVE TO TELL THEM NO.
I LIKE MY GUY, CAT TO HAVE A
DECENT GAME.
THEREFORE SNAP-A-HOLIC YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH A JERSEY OF
YOUR CHOICE.
IT'S TNT THURSDAY.
FANDUEL IS BOOSTING THE 3x2
TONIGHT IN BOTH GAMES, NOT JUST
ONE, BUT BOTH GAMES.
THE QUESTION IS, WILL THERE BE
TWO THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF THE GAME TODAY?
WE ASKED YOU ON TWITTER WHICH
3x2 WILL CASH TONIGHT?
THE LAKERS TAKING ON THE 76ers,
OR THE TIMBERWOLVES TAKING ON
THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
HERE ARE THE RESULTS.
THERE THEY ARE.
I'M NOT SURPRISED TO BE HONEST.
WHAT I NEED YOU TO DO IS GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL US WHICH
3x2 IS A LOCK.
BOTH ARE PLUS MONEY TONIGHT.
WHICH ONE IS YOUR FAVORITE?
>> YEAH.
I'M RIDING WITH THE PUBLIC HERE.
I MEAN, THIS IS A TIMBERWOLVES
TEAM THAT RANKS FIRST IN
THREE-POINTERS ATTEMPTED AND
SECOND IN THREE-POINTERS MADE.
THE WARRIORS RANK THIRD IN
THREE-POINTERS ATTEMPTED AND
FOURTH IN THREE-POINTERS MADE.
NOT TO MENTION IN THE LAST
MEETING BETWEEN THESE TWO TEAMS,
THERE WERE EIGHT ATTEMPTED
THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES.
I IMAGINE WE SEE A GAME TONIGHT
THAT IS PACED SIMILARLY.
THEY'LL TAKE A LOT OF SHOTS
EARLY FROM THE THREE-POINT LINE.
GIVE ME THE TIMBERWOLVES VERSUS
THE WARRIORS.
>> LIV IS ROCKING WITH THE
TIMBERWOLVES VERSUS THE
WARRIORS.
I'M ABOUT TO HOP IN THE
COMMENTS.
I HAVE TO SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE
ARE ROCKING WITH.
I DON'T HAVE THE iPAD TODAY, BUT
I HAVE THE HANDY DANDY PHONE
THAT VEGAS WAS CALLING ME ON.
HAD TO PUT THEM ON HOLD, BECAUSE
THIS IS "THE GROUP CHAT."
WE HAVE TO GIVE THESE LOCKS.
I SEE THE CIP99, I NEED TO
FINISH COOKING BEFORE I CAN
COMMENT.
I HOPE YOU FINISH COOKING,
BROTHER.
WE'RE GOING TO SEND YOU A
HOODIE.
WE'RE SENDING YOU A HOODIE, WHY
NOT.
WE SHOW LOVE HERE.
OFFICIALLY RONALD SAYS EASY,
BOTH GOLDEN STATE AND THE
T'WOLVES IS AN EASY LOCK.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ONE MORE IN ME.
MONEY MERV HAS STEPH CURRY
SHOOTING THE THREE GIF IN THE
COMMENTS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, YOU ARE ALSO
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
LIF
LIV, THE PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN.
I'M MAKING A DECISION.
WE'RE RIDING -- WE'RE RIDING
WITH THE MINNESOTA TIMBERWOLVES
TAKING ON THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS 3x2 TODAY.
LET'S ALL GET RICH.
LET'S TALK PLAYER POINTS FOR
TONIGHT.
MINNESOTA/GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL US YOUR BEST
BET.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE CURRENT
ODDS AND, LIV, TALK TO ME, TALK
TO THE PEOPLE AT HOME.
WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> YES, I'M HEAVY ON ANDREW
WIGGINS TONIGHT IN THIS REVENGE
GAME VERSUS HIS OLD TEAM.
THIS SEASON IN THE TWO GAMES
HE'S PLAYED THE TIMBERWOLVES, HE
AVERAGED 23.5 POINTS PER GAME.
HIS LINE IS AT 16.5.
I LOVE THAT.
HE'S FACES A TIMBERWOLVES TEAM
IN THE LAST SEVEN HAVE GIVEN UP
THE SEVENTH MOST POINTS AND THE
SECOND MOST THREES TO OPPOSING
SMALL FORWARDS.
I ALSO LIKE ANDREW WIGGINS OVER
1.5 MADE THREES HERE.
I THINK HE'S TAKING A LOT OF
SHOTS FROM THE THREE-POINT LINE.
HE HIT THIS OVER THE TWO TIMES
HE PLAYED THE WOLVES THIS
SEASON.
I LIKE HIM, REVENGE GAME IN THIS
SPOT TO SCORE WELL FOR THE
WARRIORS AND SHOOT THE THREE
BALL VERY WELL.
I'M TAKING OVER 16.5 WITH A
LITTLE SPRINKLE ON HIS THREES AS
WELL.
>> OKAY.
I SEE WHAT YOU'RE DOING THERE.
A. WIGGINS FACES HIS FORMER
TEAM, REVENGE GAME.
LET'S GET BACK AT THEM.
YOU'RE CONNECTING THE DOTS.
I SEE YOU.
I ACTUALLY WANT -- LET'S PULL
THE GRAPHIC BACK UP.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU SOMETHING.
THE TOP -- YOU GUYS SEE THAT
NAME?
KARL-ANTHONY TOWNS?
NO, HE DOESN'T PLAY FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
YES, HE PLAYS FOR THE
TIMBERWOLVES.
I'M TALKING ABOUT HIM.
HIS OVER/UNDER SITTING AT 22.5.
I'LL GO OVER.
HERE'S WHY.
HE SCORED 26 THE LAST TIME HE
FACED THE WARRIORS.
HIS HIGHEST POINT TOTAL IN THE
LAST SEVEN GAMES.
THE WARRIORS ARE ALSO A SMALL
TEAM.
RELATIVELY SMALL.
THEY DON'T HAVE JAMES WISEMAN
YET.
I THINK HE IS BIG DOWN LOW AND
COULD PUT UP SOME POINTS TODAY.
I'M ROCKING WITH K.A.T. TO GO
OVER.
I'M NOT SAYING THEY'RE GOING TO
WIN THE GAME, BUT I DO THINK
K.A.T. CAN GET HIS TONIGHT.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW,
LIV.
IT'S TIME TO GO TO THE COMMENTS.
WE GOT TO SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
WE HAVE TO GIVE AWAY HOODIES AND
WE HAVE TO GIVE AWAY JERSEYS
TODAY.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GIVING AWAY
HOODIES.
I SEE MATT SMITH 14 SAYS KLAY
ALL DAY.
HE'S ROCKING WITH KLAY'S OVER, I
ASSUME.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
SNAP IS BACK, KLAY -- HE SAYS
K.A.T. TO GO OVER 22.5.
KLAY TO HIT -- TO GO UNDER ON
THREES AND STEPH OVER ON POINTS.
YOU ALREADY GOT A HOODIE.
APPRECIATE YOU.
CHRIS BEEZY SAYS K.A.T.
DOUBLE-DOUBLE IS MONEY TONIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I
MENTIONED.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
IT'S TIME FOR MY FAVORITE PART
OF THE SHOW.
LET'S TALK MAJOR MARKETS, MONEY
LINES AGAINST THE SPREADS AND
POINT TOTALS FOR TONIGHT'S GAME.
LET'S LOOK AT THE ODDS.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING AND WHAT DO
YOU LIKE HERE?
>> WE TALKED ABOUT IT A TON
ALREADY IN THIS SHOW.
I LIKE OVER 228.5 IN THAT
TIMBERWOLVES/WARRIORS GAME.
YOU HAVE STEPH, POOLE.
I'M BANGING ON WIGGINS.
YOU LIKE K.A.T. TO HAVE A GAME.
I THINK RUSSELL WILL HAVE A BIG
GAME AS WELL.
LOTS OF THREE-POINT SHOOTERS ON
THESE TWO TEAMS.
THE TIMBERWOLVES RANK SECOND FOR
THREE-POINTERS MADE RIGHT NOW.
THE WARRIORS RANK FOURTH FOR
THREE-POINTERS MADE.
I THINK IT'S A HIGH-SCORING
AFFAIR, LOTS OF THREE-POINTERS,
LOTS OF POINTS.
GIVE ME THE OVER.
>> LIV IS ROCKING WITH THE OVER.
I DON'T DISLIKE THAT.
I DO NOT DISLIKE THAT AT ALL.
CAN WE PULL THAT GRAPHIC BACK
UP?
I WANT TO SHOW THE PEOPLE
SOMETHING.
THERE'S THE GRAPHIC.
YOU GUYS SEE THE MONEY LINE
SECTION?
I WANT TO DIBBLE AND DABBLE
THERE.
I'M NOT JUST GOING TO PICK ONE
GAME.
I'M PICKING TWO.
PARLAY.
WE'RE GOING WITH BOTH FAVORITES.
ROCKING WITH THE PHILADELPHIA
76ers TAKING ON THE LAKERS WITH
NO LeBRON.
WE KNOW HOW THEY'VE BEEN PLAYING
THIS WHOLE YEAR.
UP AND DOWN, UP AND DOWN.
I LIKE THE SIXERS.
I LIKE HOW JOEL EMBIID HAS BEEN
ON AN ABSOLUTE TEAR.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT LATER IN
THE SHOW.
I LIKE THE SIXERS IN THAT
MATCH-UP.
IN THE LATER GAME, I LIKE THE
WARRIORS.
THEY'RE ON THIS EXTENDED HOME
STAND.
THEY'RE LOOKING TO GET ON TRACK.
THEY'VE BEEN DOING FAIRLY WELL.
I THINK THEY'LL KEEP THE WINNING
GOING TODAY AGAINST THOSE
MINNESOTA TIMBERWOLVES.
LET ME TALK TO THE PEOPLE RIGHT
NOW.
LET ME HOP ON TO MY HANDY DANDY
iPHONE AND SEE WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW.
OH.
RICHIE 21 SAYS 76ers/WARRIORS
MONEY LINE PARLAY IS A LOCK.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HEADY.
BR BETTING SAYING PARLAY G.
THEY TOOK ME BACK TO VEGAS 2019
RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S WHEN I USED TO BE
PARLAYING LEFT AND RIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO BR BETTING IN THE
COMMENTS.
WHET WEYNER IS FADING MY PLAY.
LAKERS MONEY LINE, WARRIORS
MONEY LINE.
WE HERE ON "THE GROUP CHAT"
WE'RE NOT HATERS.
THOUGH YOU LIKE THE OTHER SIDE,
I'LL SEND YOU A HOODIE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
LIV, LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
SEGMENT OF THE SHOW.
WE ARE TALKING PROPS.
PROPS, PROPS.
PROPS.
WE TALKED MAJOR MARKET.
LET'S TALK PROPS.
IT'S TIME FOR LOCK OR NOT.
I'M GOING TO PUT UP A PROP, I
NEED ALL OF YOU IN THE COMMENTS
TO TELL ME WHETHER OR NOT IT'S A
LOCK OR NOT.
LIVE, ARE YOU READY?
>> I'M READY.
>> FIRST UP IS KLAY THOMPSON TO
MAKE THREE OR MORE
THREE-POINTERS AT MINUS 126.
TALK TO ME, TALK TO THE PEOPLE
AT HOME.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE OR DO YOU
NOT?
>> I DO LIKE THIS ONE.
IT GOES TO MY POINT EARLIER WITH
TAKING THE OVER.
I THINK WE SEE A LOT OF
THREE-POINT SHOTS IN THIS GAME.
I THINK IT'S HIGHLY OFFENSIVE.
AS KLAY IS FIGURING OUT HIS
OFFENSIVE ROLE ON THIS WARRIORS
TEAM AND FIGURING OUT HIS
RHYTHM, WE'RE SEEING A BIT OF UP
AND DOWN FROM HIM.
WHEN DRAYMOND GREEN STEPPED AWAY
FROM THE WARRIORS TEAM, WE SAW A
LOT OF FIGURING OUT OUR ROLES
HERE.
I THINK KLAY THOMPSON IS GETTING
THAT FIGURED OUT.
HE'S ALSO FACING A TIMBERWOLVES
TEAM THAT ON AVERAGE HAS GIVEN
UP 3.48 THREES PER GAME TO THE
OPPOSING SHOOTING GUARD
POSITION.
KLAY THOMPSON IS IN A GOOD
POSITION TO GET SOME THREES.
I'LL SAY THAT'S A LOCK.
>> LIV IS ROCKING WITH KLAY.
I'M RIGHT BEHIND YOU.
KLAY HIT THIS MARK THREE OUT OF
THE LAST FOUR GAMES HE PLAYED.
HE HIT THIS MARK, BUT THE THING
IS, THE POINT I WANTED TO MAKE
TODAY IS WE KNOW KLAY WILL PUT
UP THE SHOTS.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF THEM GOING
IN.
I FEEL CONFIDENT KNOWING THAT
KLAY THOMPSON, IF I PUT MONEY ON
HIM TO SHOOT THREE-POINTERS,
HE'S ACTUALLY GOING TO SHOOT
THOSE THREE-POINTERS.
YOU GUYS ARE GETTING WHAT I'M
SAYING?
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID, WITH
ALL THAT BEING SAID, I GOT A FEW
NUMBERS, JUST IN THE LAST FOUR
GAMES HOW MANY THREE-POINT
ATTEMPTS MY GUY KLAY THOMPSON
HAS PUT UP.
5, 7, 7 -- NO, 5, 7, 8, 8.
THE NUMBERS ARE THERE.
KLAY GO MAKE THREE OF THOSE, I
CAN SEE HIM DOING IT.
HE'S BEEN DOING IT FOR THE
MAJORITY OF HIS CAREER.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE OVER HERE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
LOOKING FOR TAKES.
LOOKING FOR LOCKS.
HERE WE GO.
I SEE SADA WILLIAMS WHO SAYS
LIFDZ, YOU ARE RIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
HERE WE GO.
D. GREEN 74, THEY NEED DRAYMOND
TO SCORE MORE EASIER.
THAT'S A GREAT, GREAT, GREAT
POINT.
DRAYMOND MAKES THIS OFFENSE
CLICK.
HE MAKES THE OFFENSE FLOW.
HE MAKES THE OFFENSE SMOOTH.
BROTHER, YOU ARE NOT WRONG ABOUT
THAT.
THEY DO NEED DRAYMOND TO MAKE
THIS OFFENSE MORE POTENT THAN
WHAT IT IS.
I THINK MY GUY, KLAY, CAN GET
THREE EVEN WITHOUT DRAYMOND.
LET'S MOVE ON.
WE GOT DeANGELO RUSSELL.
DELOADING TO HAVE EIGHT OR MORE
ASSISTS TONIGHT.
THIS IS PLUS MONEY.
TALK TO US, DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE
OR DO YOU NOT?
>> I DON'T.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
HE'S CAPABLE OF HITTING THIS
OVER.
THE REASON I'M FADING THIS IS
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY LIKE HIM IN
THE SPOT TONIGHT TO DO MORE
SCORING.
I DON'T REALLY WANT HIM TO BE
FACILITATING.
I WANT HIM TO BE SCORING POINTS.
COULD HE BE FORKING IT OVER TO
K.A.T. THROUGHOUT THE GAME TO
HELP YOU OUT WITH YOUR POINTS
PROP?
ABSOLUTELY.
THIS HAS THE POTENTIAL TO HIT.
I LIKE THIS POSITION FOR HIM IN
A SCORING PERSPECTIVE MORE THAN
AN A FACILITATING PERSPECTIVE.
I THINK HE'LL HOLD ON THE BALL
QUITE A BIT TONIGHT AND DO THE
SCORING.
I'LL SAY IT'S NOT A LOCK.
DEFINITELY POSSIBLE, BUT I LIKE
HIS ROLE TO BE MORE SCORING
TONIGHT.
>> LIV, YOU LIKE THOSE REVENGE
GAMES.
YOU MENTIONED A. WIGGINS EARLIER
SCORING TONIGHT AGAINST HIS
FORMER TEAM.
>> I DO.
>> NOW WE HAVE DELOADING FACING
HIS FORMER TEAM.
YOU SEE HIM SCORING TONIGHT.
I DON'T DISLIKE THAT.
WE SEE IT TIME AFTER TIME.
PLAYERS THAT PLAY THEIR FORMER
TEAMS USUALLY LIKE TO HAVE A
NIGHT.
THEY USUALLY DO LIKE TO HAVE A
SO I DON'T DISLIKE THAT.
BUT, LIV, I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH
THE OVER HERE.
HE HAD 12 ASSISTS LAST TIME HE
FACED THIS WARRIORS TEAM.
HIM AND K.A.T., I MENTIONED
EARLIER IN THE SHOW, I THOUGHT
K.A.T. WOULD BE SCORING TONIGHT.
THEY LIKE THE PICK AND ROLL
GAME, YOU KNOW, THE PICK AND
ROLL GAME UP TOP WHERE K.A.T.
COMES AND SETS A PICK FOR
DELOADING, AND HE THROWS HIM THE
BALL OR SHOOTS.
I SEE HIM THROWING THE BALL A
LOT.
THE WARRIORS ARE SMALL
FINISHING.
THAT RESULTS IN DELOADING
GETTING THOSE ASSISTS.
I'M ROCKING WITH DELOADING TO GO
OVER EIGHT ASSISTS.
YOU MENTIONED HE'S FACING HIS
FORMER TEAM.
MAYBE A TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
I WON'T SAY THAT.
HE PROBABLY COULD GO
DOUBLE-DOUBLE, SOMETHING.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE OVER.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
LET'S SEE WHAT THEY'RE TALKING.
MONEY MERV SAYS DELOADING IS NOT
A LOCK.
WAGS WORLD SAYS IVORY IS ON
POINT TODAY.
SHOUT OUT TO BOTH OF Y'ALL.
BEARS 4 LIFE SAID HE TRIPPING ON
THIS ONE.
I THINK HE'S TALKING ABOUT ME
TRIPPING THINKING DELOADING IS
GOING OVER.
GUESS WHAT, YOU'RE ALSO WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
LAST THREE PEOPLE I SAID, YOU'RE
WALKING AWAY WITH HOODIES.
FINALLY, LIVE, THE LAST PROP.
JARED VANDERBILT, HOW DO YOU
FEEL ABOUT THIS ONE?
>> NOT LOVING IT.
12 REBOUNDS IS A GOOD REBOUNDING
NIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S CAPABLE OF
THIS.
I ALSO THINK KARL-ANTHONY TOWNS
WILL BE GRABBING A LOT OF
BOARDS.
THAT TAKES AWAY FROM JARRED
GETTING THOSE BOARDS AND I LIKE
LOONEY TO STEP UP TONIGHT.
WE DON'T HAVE DRAYMOND GREEN FOR
THIS WARRIORS TEAM.
THAT HURT THEM IN A LOT OF WAYS.
I LOOK LOONEY TO STEP UP
TONIGHT, GET THOSE REBOUNDS.
ALSO, LIKE I SAID, KARL-ANTHONY
TOWNS WILL PROBABLY BE DOING A
BIT OF EVERYTHING TONIGHT, WHICH
INCLUDES GETTING REBOUNDS WHICH
WILL TAKE AWAY FROM THIS 12
PLUS.
I'LL SAY NOT A LOCK.
>> YEAH.
I'M RIGHT THERE WITH YOU.
12 IS A LOT.
YOU MENTIONED K.A.T. AND LOONEY.
MY GUY AVERAGES 9.2 ON THE
REGULAR SEASON.
I'M STAYING AWAY FROM THIS.
I'M NOT EVEN GOING TO BET IT.
>> AGREED.
>> I'M STAYING AWAY.
LET ME GET IN THE COMMENTS.
ALL MONEY NJC SAYS NAH, HE'LL
HAVE EIGHT BOARDS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
JARED SAID PASS.
I DON'T THINK HE'S TOUCHING THIS
ONE.
THERE'S A LOT OF NOS IN THE
COMMENTS.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
MENTIONED.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LIV, IT'S TIME TO BUILD THE B/R
BETTING SAME CUSTOM PARLAY FOR
HOME.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
LAKERS/SIXERS GAME.
I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHAT THEY
THINK.
WHICH LEGS ARE LOCKS.
WHICH LEGS ARE NOT.
WHICH LEG THEY'LL USE, WHICH LEG
THEY'LL KEEP OUT.
FILL THOSE COMMENTS UP.
LIF
LIV, ARE YOU READY?
>> LET'S JUMP INTO IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
WE HAVE JOEL EMBIID OVER 33.5
POINTS.
HE'S BEEN ON AN ABSOLUTE TEAR IN
THE MONTH OF JANUARY.
TALK TO ME.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE OR NOT?
>> YEAH, HE'S THE TYPE OF GUY
WHO WAKES UP IN THE MORNING AND
IS GOOD FOR A 30 PIECE WITH HIS
EYES CLOSED.
HE'S HARD TO GUARD RIGHT NOW.
MAYBE IMPOSSIBLE.
I THINK SCORING 30 POINTS IS
EASY FOR HIM.
NO LeBRON JAMES GIVES HIM MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET UNDER THAT
BASKET AND GET SOME SHOTS.
IT'S HARD TO FADE HIM NOW.
HE HAD 30 PLUS IN THE LAST SIX.
NO POINT IN FADING HIM TONIGHT.
I WILL RIDE WITH THIS.
I LOVE IT.
I THINK IT'S GREAT.
>> WE'RE GETTING THE GOOD VIBES
FROM LIV ON THE FIRST LEG.
NEXT LEG, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RUSSELL WESTBROOK.
OVER 18.5 POINTS.
LIV, DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE?
ARE YOU IFFY?
ARE YOU STAYING AWAY?
HOW YOU FEELING?
>> THIS IS ONE I WOULD JUST
TREAD LIGHTLY WITH.
IT'S ONE OF TWO THINGS THAT
COULD HAPPEN.
WE HAVE ANTHONY DAVIS COMING
BACK AND TRYING TO GET
REACCLIMATED TO THIS LAKERS TEAM
AND FIGURE OUT HIS ROLE.
THAT TAKES AWAY FROM WESTBROOK'S
ROLE.
BUT AT THE SAME TOKEN, NO LeBRON
JAMES GIVES WESTBROOK MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THAT
FACILITATING.
HIS OFFENSE LATELY IS
TERRIFYING.
IT'S TERRIFYING TO BET ON.
IT'S TERRIFYING TO WATCH.
HE FINALLY SEEMS LIKE HE'S
GETTING IN A RHYTHM BUT 18.5?
MAKES ME NERVOUS.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE ONE LEG I'M
NOT SURE ABOUT BECAUSE OF THE
INCONSISTENCIES WE'VE SEEN FROM
HIM IN THE PAST FEW WEEKS.
HE DOES SEEM LIKE HE'S HEATING
UP.
SO THERE IS HOPE.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
NO LeBRON JAMES, HE HAS MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SCORE.
THIS ONE MAKES ME NERVOUS.
>> YOU SAID IT RIGHT THERE.
NO LeBRON JAMES.
I THINK RUSS COMES OUT AND WILL
BE AGGRESSIVE.
IF THERE'S NO LeBRON JAMES, I
LIKE THIS ONE.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE FINAL LEG
OF THE PARLAY.
I MENTIONED IT EARLIER.
LIV, TALK TO ME.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE OR DO YOU
NOT?
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
PHILADELPHIA 76ers MONEY LINE
TONIGHT TAKING ON THOSE LOS
ANGELES LAKERS.
>> I LOVE IT.
I TALKED ABOUT THIS MANY TIMES
WITH MANY TEAMS IN THE NBA.
I THINK THE MOST DANGEROUS THING
THAT ANY NBA TEAM CAN HAVE RIGHT
NOW IS CHEMISTRY.
THE LAKERS DON'T HAVE THAT.
NOW YOU'RE REMOVING THE GLUE
THAT HOLDS THEM TOGETHER IN
LeBRON JAMES?
I DON'T FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT.
NOT THAT THEY CAN'T HANG WITH
THE 76ers EEM, BUTTEAM, BUT I T
COACHING AND OTHER THINGS ARE
MORE IMPORTANT.
LOVING PHILLY MONEY LINE.
>> I'M ALSO LOVING THE PHILLY
MONEY LINE.
I WANT TO PUT THIS TICKET UP.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU GUYS, IF YOU
WERE TO GO TO FANDUEL AND PLACE
THIS BET IN, WHAT THE ODDS WOULD
BE.
IF YOU PUT $100 DOWN, YOU WILL
BE WALKING AWAY WITH $447.18.
W
WE DID A THREE-LEG THIS TIME.
I LIKE TO CALL THESE THREE-LEG
GUARANTEES.
LIV, BEFORE I GET INTO THE
COMMENTS, WHAT ARE YOU GRADING
THE PARLAY?
>> B PLUS.
I LIKE IT.
I THINK IT CAN HIT.
AND I'M LOVING PHILLY MONEY LINE
AND EMBIID.
I'M GOING TO WISH UPON A STAR
THAT WESTBROOK DOES WHAT HE
NEEDS TO DO AND HITS IT FOR US.
PASSING GRADE.
YOU'RE STILL A GREAT STUDENT,
BUT YOUR THESIS STATEMENT WAS
OFF IN YOUR ESSAY.
NOT AN "A," BUT A "B" PLUS.
WESTBROOK JUST NEEDS TO SHOW UP.
>> B PLUS GETS THE JOB DONE.
I WANT TO SAY, LAST TIME LIV
GAVE US A "B" PLUS, WE HIT.
FEELING THE CONNECTION HERE.
IT'S TIME FOR ME TO HOP INTO
THESE COMMENTS.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND
GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
I GOT LARRY SAYING THIS WILL BE
RUSS' SHOW TONIGHT.
NO LBJ AND A.D. ON MINUTES
RESTRICTION.
LOCKED AND LOADED.
>> I LOVE THAT TAKE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS NOW.
BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
IT'S TIME TO GIVE OUT SOME
HOODIES.
SHANE CAVANS SAYS LAKERS MONEY
LINE, A.D. WILL CHECK JOEL
TONIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO HAVE ONE MORE HOODIE.
I GOT SLAY DIG 8807.
GREG, I LOVE IT.
THE SAME GAME PARPARLAY, I'M HE
FOR MY HOODIE.
HOOK ME UP.
"B" PLUS IS PASSING.
GUESS WHAT, SLAY DIG, YOU GOT
YOURSELF YOUR HOODIE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
THANK YOU FOR TAPPING IN TO THE
GROUP CHAT.
LET'S MOVE ON.
IT'S TIME TO TALK FUTURES.
TIME TO TALK FUTURES.
JOEL EMBIID IS CURRENTLY ON A
CAREER BEST HEATER RIGHT NOW.
SINCE CHRISTMAS HE LEADS THE
LEAGUE IN SCORING AND IS TOP 15
IN REBOUNDS AND BLOCKED SHOTS.
HE'S CLOSING IN ON THE FAVORITE
POSITION TO WIN MVP.
TODAY WE ASKED YOU ON THE APP IF
JOEL EMBIID CAN WIN MVP.
I NEED YOU TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHETHER HE
CAN OVERTAKE STEPH AND GIANNIS.
LET'S LOOK AT THE ODDS.
LIVE, DO WHAT YOU DO BEST.
TALK TO US.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON MVP ODDS?
>> GREG, I HATE TO BREAK IT TO
YOU.
THERE'S NO DISRESPECT HERE, BUT
STEPH CURRY IS TOO HIGH.
I DON'T AGREE WITH WHERE HE IS
SITTING RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T THINK HE'S PLAYING LIKE
AN MVP.
MVP MEANS MOST VALUABLE PLAYER.
WHO BRINGS THE MOST VALUE TO
THIS WARRIORS TEAM?
WE'RE NOT SEEING THAT FROM
STEPH.
I'M STARTING TO WONDER IF
DRAYMOND GREEN IS NOT THE MVP
BECAUSE WE SAW COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT VERSION OF THEM WHEN
DRAYMOND GREEN WAS OUT.
THAT'S NOT TO DENY STEPH CURRY'S
TALENT.
HE'S STILL INSANELY TALENTED.
YOU'RE UP AGAINST GIANNIS,
EMBIID, JOKIC.
THAT'S MY TOP THREE.
I THINK STEPH CURRY NEEDS TO BE
MOVED DOWN A BIT.
NOT IMPRESSED WITH WHAT HE'S
DOING.
EMBIID IS PLAYING LIKE AN MVP.
I THINK IT'S A BIT OF A
POPULARITY CONTEST.
THEY'LL GO WITH WHO PEOPLE LOVE.
I LOVE EMBIID, I DON'T KNOW IF
EVERYBODY LOVES EMBIID.
FOR THAT REASON, IT'S GOOD
VALUE, I WOULD GRAB IT BECAUSE I
THINK HE'S PLAYING LIKE AN MVP.
I WOULD SAY GIANNIS AND JOKIC
ARE MY TOP TWO.
AND I HAVE A PLUS 3200 BET ON
JOHN MORANT.
>> I LIKE THE JOHN MORANT PICK.
LIV, I MEAN, I'M BEHIND YOU.
I JUST THINK JOEL EMBIID, YOU
CAN CONSIDER SPRINKLING SOME
MONEY ON HIM.
THE WAY HE'S BEEN PLAYING, HE'S
BEEN BALLING.
YOU JUST HOPE AND PRAY -- I PRAY
MY GUY STAYS HEALTHY.
THAT'S IT.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE MONTH
JOEL EMBIID HAD IN JANUARY.
I WILL LIST OFF SOME OF HIS
POINT TOTALS FOR THE MONTH.
42, 38, 40, 50.
32, 32, 25, 31, 31, 31.
COME ON.
MY GUY HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
BALLING.
>> NUTS.
>> THERE'S A REASON HE'S NEXT TO
STEPH CURRY AND GIANNIS.
LIV, YOU SAID SOME INTERESTING
THI
THINGS.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
I WILL AGREE WITH YOU.
THE LAST MONTH MY GUY HAS NOT
BEEN PLAYING LIKE HOW HE WAS
EARLIER IN THE SEASON.
BUT LET'S NOT FORGET HOW HE WAS
PLAYING EARLIER IN THE SEASON.
HE WAS ON A TEAR.
>> I NEED CONSISTENCY.
THAT'S ALL.
THERE'S TIME.
THERE'S SO MUCH TIME LEFT.
HE ABSOLUTELY -- I'M NOT WORRIED
ABOUT STEPH CURRY.
IT'S JUST, YOU KNOW, RIGHT NOW,
NOT REALLY FEELING HIS VIBE AT
THE MOMENT.
HE'S GOT TIME.
LATELY HE HASN'T BEEN DOING WHAT
HE'S BEEN DOING MAJORITY OF THE
YEAR.
I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THAT.
I UNDERSTAND YOUR POINT.
I JUST WANT YOU AND THE PEOPLE
AT HOME TO REMEMBER, PLEASE
REMEMBER WHAT THIS MAN WAS DOING
EARLIER IN THE SEASON.
I JUST THINK MY GUY STEPH GOT
HEAVY LEGS.
HE'S GOT HEAVY LEGS.
HE'S BEEN BATTLING.
HE'S BEEN CARRYING THE WARRIORS
TEAM ESPECIALLY BEFORE KLAY.
GUESS WHAT?
GUESS WHAT'S RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER?
THE ALL-STAR BREAK.
THERE'S A LOT OF BASKETBALL
AFTER THE ALL-STAR BREAK.
MY GUY WILL REST UP HIS LEGS AND
GO ON THIS PLAYOFF PUSH.
YOU GUYS WILL SEE.
I'M STILL ROCKING WITH THE HOME
TEAM.
I'M ROCKING WITH STEPH.
JOEL EMBIID, HE'S CATCHING MY
EYE.
I'M WILLING TO SPRINKLE SOME
MONEY ON IT.
LIVED, WE REACHED THE END.
THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY FOR
TAPPING IN TO "THE GROUP CHAT."
PLEASE REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED
TODAY.
THE WARRIORS TIM BEFORE WOLVES
TIMBERWOLVES, THAT'S A LOCK.
IF YOU LIVE IN LOUISIANA, GET ON
FANDUEL AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE EARLY $100 THEY'RE GIVING
YOU FOR SIGNING UP.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT WEEK GIVING
OUT MORE HOODIES, MORE JERSEYS
AND MORE LOCKS.
IF YOU WANT A HOODI
-- WON
WE WILL DM YOU.
ME AND LIV, WE'RE LEAVING THE
GROUP CHAT.
PEACE.